hello I'm Tom Cohen I'm the head
instructor for
fifteen six six two how to secure the
dream for the next generation workforce
I'd like to take a little time to tell
you a little bit about myself and why
I'm offering this course I've been
studying and teaching and working on
issues about the nature of work for the
last 40 years I've never been more
concerned about the future of work than
I am right now
I'm concerned about the need for more
jobs better jobs for you and for all
people in the next generation and so I
think we can work together in this
course to explore how you can address
these issues and secure your future as
well so let me tell you a little bit
about my background and so you can
understand where I'm coming from I grew
up on a small family farm in Wisconsin
we learned at a very early age the
importance of working together the value
of hard work and the satisfaction that
comes from doing a job very well my
father only had an eighth grade
education but he told all of us my
brother and my sisters get as much
education as you can so that you can get
an occupation and a career that is
better than what farming will be in the
future that was clearly the best advice
I could have ever gotten and it worked
Here I am many years later an MIT
professor thanks to a good education
from the schools in Wisconsin and from
the University of Wisconsin so in my
professional life I've been fortunate to
work with a wide variety of business and
labor and government organizations over
the years and I've been a constant
advocate for improving relations at the
workplace for getting people to work
together to think about how the
workforce is changing and how they need
to change to meet the conditions of the
economy and the society and the
workforce that we find ourselves in and
so that's what I want to do in this
course to engage you the next generation
workers and those of us in the baby boom
generation who still care about these
issues and want to make a contribution
to a discussion of how we can improve
the workplace and I want to especially
learn and listen from you I'm engaged in
writing a book on this topic and I want
to get your ideas so you help shape how
we're going to change how we're going to
adapt and how we're going to create the
workplace of the future
I'm Barbara Dyer president and CEO of
the Hitachi foundation and senior
lecturer at MIT Sloan School of
Management the Hitachi foundation
focuses on the role of business in
society with a particular emphasis on
how businesses create social and
economic value in the pursuit of profits
we'll be talking about startup companies
and their motivation to create a real
benefit for society and we'll be talking
some about traditional businesses more
long term businesses and the ways in
which they create social value and
environmental value and the lessons that
can be learned across the spectrum from
early-stage businesses to later stage
businesses I'm Zeynep Tong I'm an
adjunct associate professor at MIT Sloan
in the operations management group I
will tell you about how we can create
companies that deliver great value to
their investors good jobs to their
employees and great value to their
customers all at the same time I'm
Kristine Riordan a PhD student at MIT s
Institute for work and employment
research I am going to be talking to you
about how labor unions are reinventing
themselves and how new forms of worker
advocacy can help support your
aspirations for work I'm Francesca
cecelio an undergraduate at MIT I'm
going to tell you more about what our
generation the so-called Millennials say
are their goals and aspirations for work
and their version of the American dream
hello my name is John McCarthy I'm a
postdoctoral fellow here at MIT
Institute for work in employment
research I'm going to be talking to you
about freelancing work including new
technology mediated work arrangements
that are springing up across the economy
we're going to look at some of the
positive and negative aspects of these
work arrangements and also talk about
how work institutions
might emerge to ameliorate some of the
negative aspects of these work
arrangements so I hope we will learn
together and then let's take our lessons
and our message to the broader audiences
to future leaders in this country and
around the world
you